hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast 1.25 that I hydroxy vitamin D
testing and its clinical significance hi
I'm Robert caste alumnus of Lavin's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by the asan the
authority operated offers the Brahmas
fully automated infectious disease and
specialty diagnostic menu including the
best-in-class vitamin D these quality
ASAE's are analyzed on the versatile
liaison excel platform they provide
value through sales service and support
solutions to clinical laboratories by
consolidating their menu in order to
streamline processes and increase
efficiency for more information please
visit the asourian comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or to submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of attaining your credits I'd like to
introduce today's speaker the dr. Armand
Zittel Minh professor dr. Armand
Zimmermann is a head of the Center for
clinical studies and thoracic and
cardiovascular surgery at the heart and
Diabetes Center in Germany dr. Zimmerman
also lectures at the Institute of
nutrition and food Sciences at the
University of Bonn on specific aspects
of food security his research focuses in
the prevalence and consequences of
insufficient levels of vitamin D in
humans think particularly in patients
with cardiovascular diseases diseases
furthermore dr. Zimmerman investigates
the confounding factors on outcomes of
cardiac tech surgery patients including
the influence of immunosuppressants in
heart transplant patients his scientific
work includes the various fields such as
biochemistry physiology epidemiology
nutrition heart surgery and statistics
dr. cinnamon has published more than 200
journal and book articles and has
presented more than 250 lectures
national and international he is a
reviewer for a number of international
scientific journals and serves on the
editorial board of very nutritional
medicine journals I'll now turn it over
to dr. determines for this presentation
hello everyone also for me first
Alan if you know you and we make some
general remarks on vitamin D then I will
talk about laboratory aspects about
actions of vitamin D about clinical
aspects and then I will draw some
conclusions group of steroid hormones
consists of four members and vitamin D
is one of these four members and as you
probably know there are two vitamin D
sources for humans vitamin D synthesis
in the skin after you will be exposure
and a vitamin D intake in vitamin D
itself is inactive and it has to be
metabolized in the so called in the in
the human body first in the level into
25 hydroxy vitamin V and if the vitamin
D of the 25 or a key level is low in the
human body you can
this by vitamin D supplements 11 the
active hormonal form of vitamin D is a
125 dihydroxy vitamin d and the case but
used in the kidneys and it's tightly
regulated and two minerals are important
for the regulation of 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d and this is plasma calcium and
plasma phosphate and this regulation is
mediated by two hormones the culture
topic PTH is enough it's increased for
example it's plasma calcium levels are
low and then PTH is responsible for an
increase in circulating 125 guy had op C
vitamin B level and the other hormone is
fqf 23 it supports Petula convoy and
this hormone is upregulated it plots
macular phosphate levels are high and
this upregulation of fqf
worth 23 results in a decrease in
circulating 125 I had oxy vitamin
mineral and now I will come to some
laboratory aspects up to now 125 died
her top C vitamin D measurement has been
neglect like neglected for several
reasons first there is a homeostatic
regulation in circulating 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d levels at least in healthy
individuals second the active hormonal
form of like 'man D has a relatively
short plasma half-life and the third
aspect is that up to now measurement was
very difficult and high sample volumes
and
they required extensive purification and
separation and here you can see a meta
data from a meta analysis and this data
they show the results of studies of
vitamin D supplements on total 18 125
dollar dot C vitamin D levels and here
you can see that Julian test kits they
show different results compared to other
test kits and this demonstrates that up
to now the measurement of 125 dihydroxy
vitamin D was difficult and we look at
reactions of 125 dihydroxy vitamin D we
can say that almost all tissues in the
human body every 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
receptors for example muscle bone heart
and circulation brain and nervous system
and also the immune system and the
active form of vitamin D has economic
and non-economic cellular vitamin D
actions and therefore a classical
steroid hormone and the genomic actions
are mediated by a citrus Olek vitamin d
receptor the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d in
the circulation it bound to this cycle
solid vitamin d receptor and to 125
dihydroxy vitamin d can also bind to a
membrane-bound vitamin d receptor and
this receptor is responsible for the
middle for the Esper for the non-genomic
vitamin d reactions but it's also
possible the 25 hydroxy vitamin D is
taken by some tissues and they are able
to produce the active
common form of vitamin him but all by
themselves and here you can see that
several types of tissues are able to
produce about $25 oxy vehemently by
themselves
for example immune cells also bone cells
cells of the gastrointestinal system
also cells of the vascular system and
for example a pancreatic beta cells and
to be know that vitamin D has several
modes of action it's well-known that
vitamin D has endocrine functions as I
mentioned before it's important for the
regulation of T minerals of calcium and
phosphate in the plasma but it has also
auto clean and poverty of ikana vitamin
D reactions in several tissues for
example in the immune system also in the
beta cells of the pancreas and it's also
important in tumor cells for the
regulation and defined selection of
these cells and it's important to know
that the uptake of 25 hydroxy vitamin D
equal to target cells
well 125 dihydroxy vitamin D can be made
by these cells themselves that this
uptake depends on the concentration of
195 the hydroxy vitamin D in the
circulation for example you have a
patient with renal impairment and if you
have these patients they have a lower
octave of 25 hydroxy vitamin D into the
target cells compared with patients who
have normal kidney function and if you
administer the active hormonal form of
vitamin D
1:25 dihydroxy vitamin D which is also
called healthy Kyle to these patients
the uptake of 25 hydroxy vitamin D into
the target cells is also increased and
now I want to come to some clinical
aspects one 2500 oxy vitamin D can be
measured in the circulation and the
reference range is between 25 and 87
picogram per million and it's well known
that the circulating level of 125
dihydroxy vitamin d is low for example
in patients with chronic kidney disease
it's also low in patients with
hyperthyroidism of sodium high poverty
realism and the time in patients with
primary hyperparathyroidism and in these
cases one can use measurement of 125
third I had oxalic Lundeen for
confirmatory reasons but we can also use
it for diagnostic reasons for example
some patients may have hypercalcemia
and this hypercalcemia may be amused by
high 125 that I had roxie vitamin D
levels in the circulation for example in
patients with sarcoidosis or historical
losses and here we can use the test for
measurement 125 by hydroxy vitamin D and
there are also two forms of vitamin D
dependent rickets type one whether one
alpha hydroxy low hydroxylase is very
low and the circulating 125 the hydroxy
vitamin D is very low and also vitamin D
dependent rickets type - well the 125
dihydroxy vitamin D is very high in the
circulating in the circulation because
there is a vitamin D receptor defect but
these types of vitamin D depend
crickets are very rarely seen in the
clinical setting and they are not the
same as the nutritional vitamin D
recapped but it's important to use the
tester to differentiate these different
forms of vitamin D depending on crickets
and none of along to talk about some
more diseases first of all about chronic
kidney disease and it's well known that
in taking Western societies chronic
kidney disease is very prevalent and we
also know that in patients with renal
impairment also the Sakya laking 125
dihydroxy vitamin D level goes down and
for example in patients with CPP stage 3
we have usually a level below the lower
limit of the reference range this means
between below 25 picograms panel and
here you can see that if plasma helps
you plasma 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
levels decrease when some increase in to
this update on in other words if there
is an increase 10 picograms per
milliliter in plasma 125 10 hydroxy
vitamin D then this is associated with
the better survival in the patient and
this is also independent of age
ethnicity
diabetes cardiovascular disease history
PTH levels the only factor which was
attenuated this aspect is association
between 125 dihydroxy vitamin D levels
and poor clinical outcome was at EF 23
and this is
understandable because this is a very
important hormone which regulates the
circulating level of 125 dollar oxy
vitamin D and this study could also show
here if you look at those patients who
have very low 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
levels for example below 15 picograms
per milliliter this was associated with
the iron in the higher risk of death or
collection in chronic dialysis and
compared to patients who head to 125 die
Glocke C vitamin D levels above 25
because per milliliter and in the
right-hand column you can see the dose
was 125 Tiger oxy vitamin D levels
between 15 and 22 picograms per
milliliter
they had a risk of desk or collection of
chronic dialysis in the media range so
the 125 dihydroxy vitamin D is a good
predictor for poor clinical outcome in
patients with chronic kidney disease and
here you can see meta-analysis about the
hazard ratio of all cause mortality for
vitamin D treatment that is no treatment
in chronic kidney disease patients and
you can see if you look at the summary
on the bottom line then you can see
those who have the treated with vitamin
D there's different forms of vitamin D
it's the active form of vitamin D and
also the tentative form of vitamin D
they had a lower risk of all-cause
mortality
approximately 25%
of all cause mortality and another meta
meta analysis on activated vitamin D in
all cause mortality could show that this
that was an effect of a time period of
screen years and also of five years and
and the risk ratio was the news by
approximately one-third but you also
have to keep in mind that these are
observational studies and meta-analysis
of observational studies and that we
still need more randomized controlled
trials for these associations and to
prove causality and here as you can see
the effect of activated vitamin D on
circulating 125 or G levels in the lower
part of this slide and what you can also
see that the effect of activated vitamin
D on circulating 125 G is only based on
three studies this means that only three
randomized controlled trials are
available and that we need more on
randomized controlled trials to look on
the effect of activated vitamin D on
circulation on circulating 125 and you
can also see that the world wide range
in the effect of activated for vitamin D
on the circulation and therefore I
personally believe that it's very
important to do the measurement of 125
dihydroxy vitamin D also in patients who
are treated with activated vitamin D and
to do follow-up measurements of 125 by
hydroxy vitamin D levels in order to see
this treatment is able to result in the
circulating 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
level which is another fine change and
now I want to talk about some life style
aspects and you can see that for example
in the summer season the 25 hydroxy
vitamin D levels are higher in healthy
individuals than in during the winter
season because of UV exposure and the
skin the synthesis of vitamin D and this
high or 25 hydroxy vitamin D level is
also associated to the higher one 25
hydroxy vitamin D level in the
circulation therefore it's important to
guarantee adequate vitamin D status and
this has also an effect on the
circulating 125 hydroxy vitamin D level
but not only the vitamin D air supply is
important this investigation should
could show that also other diseases are
obviously able to influence the
circulating 125 I have oxy vitamin e
level you can see that for example the
kidney function gia bar and also we know
the placement as an independent and
significant aspect influence on the
circulating 125 dynabox vitamin D has
already been shown but in this slide you
can also see that for example diabetes
or the away click on the CRP level is
inversely related significantly
inversely related to circulating one
twenty-five die hard oxy vitamin D
levels and proximately twenty years ago
I had the opportunity to do study during
the German nationals space mission in
the German cosmonaut and what we did we
measured the PTH to 25 hydroxy vitamin D
and also the 125 hydroxy vitamin D
pre-flight in-flight and post-flight
and what you can see here is that 25
hydroxy vitamin D and also the PTH
remained fairly constant during this
time however there was a marked decrease
in one $25 oxy vitamin D levels until
the end of the observed flight and also
you on the first day supposed like this
demonstrate that that 125 dihydroxy
vitamin D level it's not tightly
regulated and there are situations where
our mark influences and mark
observations in the circulating level of
this hormone and as we all know physical
activity it's very important for healthy
lives and we should do physical activity
every day and there are several reasons
why physical activity is good for our
health and increasingly physical
activity has also the positive effect on
circulating 125k hydroxy vitamin D level
as seen in this slide for example
physically active individuals in the
left hand side of this slide have higher
circulating 125 hydroxy vitamin D levels
than young sedentary name and also
immobilization has an effect on the
circulating 125 echovox vitamin d
as you can see on the right hand side
the mobilization is associated with the
decrease in 125 vitamin D and the
mobilization is associated with an
increase in 125 dihydroxy vitamin D and
all I want to talk about another room
disease it's heart failure and similar
to chronic kidney disease heart failure
is very prevalent in the aching Western
society and heart failure patients have
several dealing the arrangements the
metabolism and one of these arrangements
imbalances in calcium and phosphate
metabolism and this can also lead to
advanced heart failure and it's well
known that the fgf 20 series it was
thought to like hormone which is
important for the regulation of
circulating 125 or G is increased in
patients with heart failure and it's
very good predictor of high levels a lot
a good predictor of poor clinical
outcome in these patients and not only
the fgf 23 but also the y 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is a good predictor of
clinical outcome yeah you can we have
the results of a cohort study in 500
patients with a high prevalence of
end-stage heart failure and you can see
the value mortality was significantly
higher in those patients who had the
baseline 25 hydroxy vitamin D 125
hydroxy vitamin D levels below 25
picograms per milliliter
and this is another study from my group
compelled him and they could show
similar results they could demonstrate
that in patients with heart failure
cardiovascular deaths was significantly
higher in those patients who had to low
additional 125
dihydroxy vitamin D levels and what we
also did we looked at the outcome in
patients with end-stage heart failure
and on clinical outcomes for example
that's transplantation and mechanical
circulatory support implant and to use a
bit score and this was score was
consisted of five different biochemical
parameters and one of these parameters
was 125 dihydroxy vitamin D low levels
of 125 dihydroxy vitamin D was
associated with a higher risk of poor
clinical outcome and also high levels of
FDF 23 was associated with higher risk
and it was possible to reach five points
with this red score score and those who
is got five points that a much higher
risk of poor clinical outcome than those
with zero point services was gone and
what we also investigated was the
association between mechanical
circulatory support implants and also
collecting 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
levels at the beginning just before
implantation all patients had very long
125 dihydroxy vitamin D levels and
interestingly the nonsurvivors also did
not survive the first pass of
yeah they had 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
level remained below but in those who
survived the first post-operative year
in those patients 125 diadochi vitamin D
level increased significantly until the
end of the follow-up Avenue period this
also shows that obviously the 125 dollar
oxy vitamin D the good predictor of poor
clinical outcome in heart failure
patients and here you can see that this
association is also present in Hawkins
plant recipients again you can see that
those who had the lowest 125 died had
oxy vitamin D levels at the end of one
year for luckily it's beginning of the
one-year follow-up period they had the
lowest term survival and those with the
highest 125 third I had rocks vitamin D
level just after her confrontation they
had the highest survival at the end of
the first post-operative year and these
were multi variable adjusted data all
this data I showed you a multi variable
adjusted and they indicate the
independent association between the
circulating level of 125 dihydroxy
vitamin D and clinical outcome and they
are formed to my opinion we can add
another aspect the measurement of 125
dihydroxy vitamin D can also be a risk
not come off premature deaths in heart
failure patients
and there is some and some evidence that
probably 125 dynabox vitamin D is also
predictive for survival in other words
of patience we need more research in
this field but it's interesting for
example the impatient with zebb says and
that those would go head very low well I
95 died oxy vitamin D level initially
that they had a relatively high
mortality rate and that in a multi
variable model 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
total calcium and age the very important
predictors of 30-day survival in this
study
nevertheless there are several gaps in
present knowledge about the circulating
125 that oxy vitamin D level as I
mentioned before only a few randomized
controlled trials have investigated the
effect of activated or alternative
vitamin D on circulating 125 or G levels
and and it's also unclear whether the
rest causality between low circulating
125 tyleroxley vitamin d and poor
clinical outcome several observational
studies indicate that there may be an
association but we need more randomized
controlled clinical trials and also the
effect of different diseases in the end
of some lifestyle factors like physical
activity on circulating 125 dialogue c
vitamin d has to be studied more detail
so now i can come to my conclusion
circulating 125 diet oxy vitamin d it's
less tightly regulated has been assumed
so far and may include
to become a reliable predictor of
clinical outcome in some clinical
conditions more attention should be paid
on follow-up measurements of circulating
125 or HD in patients treated will
activate the vitamin D however it's also
necessary to look at the plasma or serum
calcium level and urinary calcium
because one activated vitamin D can also
lead to iPAQ atheneum and this has to be
prevented therefore it's important to
measure these calcium levels but also
it's important to do follow-up
measurements of the circulating 125 I
had Aqsa litem indeed to prevent high
levels of this active hormone in the
circulation thank you for your attention
[Music]
well thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on a
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green - na
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can as time
allows so doctor our first question is
would you explain the ways to prevent
low levels of active vitamin D
the there are several aspects which are
important first it's important to have
an adequate vitamin D intake and for
example if you do not have adequate you
will be exposure to your skin you can
use vitamin D supplements but it seems
to be also that it's important to do
adequate physical activity because
physical activity can increase 125 died
had oxy vitamin D level and then in this
context it's also important to Caban
immobilization and that seems to be an
association between dietary phosphate in
cake and to 125 type of cervical Mandi
diets high in dietary phosphate they may
suppress the active hormonal form of
vitamin D so you can even the healthy
individuals can do a lot to to prevent
low circulating 125 diet oxy likely
levels
thank you our next question is what is
the definition of at risk for chronic
kidney disease
yes those who have a chronic kidney
disease stage 3 4 5 they are at risk for
low circulating 125 ty had oxy vitamin D
levels and those who have CKD stage 3
they may use a vitamin D supplement
however those who are have 60 stage 4
and 5 they should use activated vitamin
D then our next question is what causes
the 1.25 dinah hydroxy vitamin D
decrease in spaceflight
so in low gravity conditions also in
sedentary lifestyles
yeah it's a very good question
one aspect maybe helps young increase in
the in the circulation because of bone
loss for example you'll microgravity
there is a bone loss it's well
documented and this leads to an increase
in plasma calcium and this plasma
calcium level it's responsible for down
regulation of the circulating 125
dihydroxy vitamin E but this is probably
not the whole story by example which is
there is accumulating evidence that
inflammatory cytokines suppress the
circulating 125 dihydroxy like any level
and for example you on the German
Russian space flight there was a lot of
stress earlier doing this mission
because there was a fire on board the
station and it's known that inflammatory
cytokines are increased in case of from
Earth stress and this may also influence
the circulating 195 DynaVox vitamin D
level in these conditions
but look like with the time that we have
allotted we have time for one more
question
how do you explain the 1.25 dihydroxy
vitamin D suppression in heart failure
patients yeah these patients have very
high fgf 423 levels and as I mentioned
before the fgf 23 is a very good
predictor for poor clinical outcome in
heart failure and the fgf 23 is a
phosphor to leak hormone and it's up
regulated in case of from high plasma
phosphate levels and this hormone is
also responsible for the down regulation
of circulating 125 daya Doxil I can be
level dr. Zillman I want to thank you
very much for your time and not only for
your wonderful presentation but also for
going through the questions that we have
today
and before we let you go do you have any
final comments for today yes but
a permanent form of vitamin D is a very
potent the sterotype hormone and there
is accumulating evidence that it's
influenced by lifestyle factors but also
by several diseases and therefore to my
opinion we should pay more attention to
the circulating 125 Skyhawks vitamin d
level in the clinical setting but also
we have to do more scientific research
in this field well thank you again
doctor for that wonderful presentation
I'd also like to thank our sponsor
dear Sauron for making today's
educational webcasts possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through may 2017 you'll receive
an email alert from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to for that
announcement to any colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye